police and soldiers in kampala prepare
to go out on night patrols there's a
cafe in place because of covet 19 but
the patrols are now more frequent and
thorough following attacks by three men
who detonated explosive devices killing
themselves and other people near a
police station and parliament last
tuesday
george katana who had a shop on
parliament avenue was one of four
civilians who were killed
he was the breadwinner of a big family
his son says he was tough but loving
could push you to something
like school
we have gone into good schools
but with no
man he has been there for us
the attack comes off the back of two
others in october one at a restaurant in
the city and another on a bus that was
travelling to western uganda
the government has blamed the allied
democratic forces with roots in uganda
but now based in the eastern democratic
republic of congo's north kivu province
this is not a military conflict
it's more of an intelligence-led
campaign
you just need to find out who and where
adf fighters have carried out a series
of attacks and killings in recent years
including an assassination attempt in
june on general katumba mala the roads
minister his daughter and driver died in
that attack
isil has claimed the most recent
incidents in the name of its central
african administrative branch adf is
said to have links to it
about a hundred people have been
arrested and 12 others killed by
security forces in the last five months
police say they are all linked to adf
and some have been actively recruiting
young ugandans to join the ranks
some security experts say killing
suspects could be harmful to the fight
against what the government calls
terrorism if we don't get very very
careful as operational and they die they
die then we are turning them into
matters we make we are we are turning
their relatives into matters because
they will now have reason to join what
they believe what they not possibly
believe in
life is coming back to normal in kampala
following the explosions some ugandans
are worried about the possibility of
more attacks but they also say they are
determined not to live in fear catherine
soy al jazeera kampala uganda